[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça se passe là et si vous aimez la table
exclusive sont maintenant première info
exclusive j'ai pas de relance comment
faire la radio tu te démerdes Myriam
alors
c'est très sympa de revenir
[Musique]
[Rires]
info de la Star Academy il faut savoir
que l'album du finaliste a été déjà
programmé les chansons sont prêtes la
production a déjà tout fait et ce qui
est assez exceptionnel c'est que nous
avons trois artistes de renom qui
pour préparer cet album à savoir Vita
Slimane et Vianney c'est pas rien on
adore
il ressemblera pas forcément la
personnalité du gagnant parce qu'il est
déjà fait oui
déjà pas mal
je commence à comprendre pourquoi Julien
il joue pas le jeu pardon je vous
apprends quelque chose c'était pareil
pour Jennifer l'album
de soleil
le but c'est quand même de sortir
l'album des gens viennent donc on va
aller très très vite je sais pas si vous
souvenez ils ont fait venir Lara Fabian
pendant pendant l'émission et en fait
ils l'ont elle a fait une Master Class
en fait c'est une façon pour eux de
tester de tester en fait Lara Fabian ce
qu'ils aimerait bien que l'année
prochaine elle elle intègre le corps
professoral de l'émission
Star Academy et The Voice et du coup
elle sera libre une année et ils
adoreraient la voir dans le jury l'année
prochaine
donc c'est comme ça
alors
les quotidiens là c'est que Lara Fabian
donnait tous les conseils inverses
Adeline moi j'adore pas dégoûté
par semaine voilà donc
le casting de la saison 2 est lancé
alors les infos devrait le lancer
justement ce soir lancer le nouveau
casting parce que la deuxième saison de
la Star Academy enfin de cette version
là est en cours de négociation et c'est
en bonne voie pour qu'elle soit faite
pour qu'elle soit faite et avec le même
volume d'émission ou justement
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que certains
profs ils seront pas tous là l'année
prochaine donc on a Adeline et Yanis
Marshall qui eux vont être conduits par
contre
et leur bah alors ballon elle je pense
que tu es content elle ne sera pas elle
ne seront certes ils seront certainement
pas là l'année prochaine mais moi alors
bah non je suis passé moi j'aime bien
ça sert à rien déjà dans les précédentes
ça sert à rien enfin
je peux ne pas être d'accord avec vous
franchement c'est l'un des seuls cours
qui m'a aidé dans ce dans
faut savoir improviser quoi c'est pour
ça que je te dis ça c'est que c'est pas
c'est pas rien c'est des conneries c'est
sûr mais c'est pas rien à faire et
confiance
[Rires]
je vais prendre des cours de théâtre
cours Florent tout nananas et moi j'ai
arrêté tout de suite parce que ça me va
pas et pour ça que le premier cours elle
en était comme ça à 5 6 et il y a
toujours une prof qui n'a pas fait de
carrière c'est le principe d'un prof de
théâtre et qui te dit en général viens
au centre et maintenant tu dois faire
une couleur non fais-moi une tomate mûre
oui la tartine beurrée et là toi tu es
comme ça tu sais pas trop fais-moi une
tomate mûre alors tu es là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu ça moi j'avoue que j'ai du
mal mais si tu me dis que ça t'aider ah
ouais ça m'a aidé de fou moi vraiment
de l'émission
avec lui parce que je sais pas si vous
avez remarqué mais à chaque évaluation
ils étaient tous bien assis à une place
et lui il était toujours dans un coin de
table sans feuille sans chaise comme ça
sur le coton durant un peu vrai pour non
mais c'est vrai donc il était pas non
plus très élevé par l'approche je trouve
dommage mais il va revenir faire revenir
Oscar systeau
est-ce que sur la finale qui est à 22h
donc c'est parti tu avais le temps et
toi aussi de prendre le bus est-ce que
tu vas sur la finale bien sûr bah oui
bien sûr comme j'ai dit vous allez tous
faire l'entrée exactement
vous savez qu'on est pas sur tinder
Julien arrivé tu sais la musique part
ils sont assis puis tu ne contestan
[Rires]
Déborah non Morini
et tu l'auras ton petit ami aussi comme
sortira très bien est-ce que question
pour Julien j'ai d'autres infos
[Rires]
sinon Michael Goldman n'a toujours pas
signé pour l'année prochaine mais il
pourrait certainement revenir comme
directeur de la Star Ac et la dernière
info je te coupe il était bien comme
directeur ou pas incroyable
s'éteignent et tout ça
il est pareil que ce soit devant les
caméras hors des caméras c'est un génie
et vraiment il est génial vraiment il
est génial d'accord c'est ce qui paraît
aussi moi j'ai trouvé incroyablement
plein de cariste et tout ça c'est sûr
qu'avec vous il soit il soit comme ça
les chats font pas de chien les chats ne
font pas de chien par exemple sur le
fils de
majeur compagnie voilà il a trouvé plein
de talents donc là il était vraiment
comme un peu effacé c'est dommage
par rapport à Alexia la rue Joubert et
cetera je trouve un peu il est très
talentueux mais je trouve en tant que
directeur un petit peu incroyable
un peu effacé pour moi ouais quand même
hein
la dernière info exclusive c'est qu'une
tournée avec les 8 derniers candidats
étant préparation il chanteront en fait
les meilleurs prestations des différents
prime
de fou et dans 2 minutes ce sera plus au
tarif de la tournée
et qui va produire
et on me dit que le casting sera ouvert
ce soir donc tu vas y aller je m'inscris
moi